foreign
wakes up in the morning not even again
Hitler or Putin or whoever you want to
come up as an example nobody comes up in
the morning wakes up in the morning goes
to the mirror and and does the Disney
villain thing like whoa what kind of
evil can I do today
no they they they think they're doing
the right thing I mean Putin has
justifications to himself and to the
world for what he's doing and so did
Hitler and so the Mussolini etc etc the
question therefore is well should we buy
those justifications so like I don't
think of Hitler as a Universalist or or
Putin as a Universalist and if they
think of themselves that way they just
don't understand what universalism
actually is so no I think that if we
take universalism is more
cosmopolitanism or however whatever word
you want to use seriously then it really
does follow that certain actions are not
not acceptable and I don't see how one
could reasonably use them use those
ideas as in defense of those actions the
fact that people do anyway because lots
of people don't reason particularly well
or they don't pay particular attention
to uh philosophy or or facts on the
ground that's that's a fact of human
life but no I cannot honestly imagine
somebody who says I'm a Cosmopolitan
therefore I'm entitled to kill half of
the world because they don't look like
me that's like you just don't understand
but that's a very common Cosmopolitan
idea for Europe in a certain period no
it isn't it is absolutely not for
example so for example no I mean it
actually is I mean my second book was on
how Josiah Roy's literally introduces
the notion of cosmopolitanism and
idealism on the basis of enslaving a
whole group of people in the early 20th
century and he had this debate even at
the University of Aberdeen in their
philosophical Society like trying to
figure out how anglo-saxonism could be
extended over German idealism as a
justification for our Anglo-Saxons
democracy right but what that is is a
very good example of rationalization
right but you but you have centuries and
centuries of right but this is what I
mean say like you're in our time we're
saying that this doesn't fit with what
we think the rationalization would be
but then from the 18th to 19th century
you have all the letters and the and the
premier institutions of Europe that are
centers of philosophy endorsing the very
same argument this is a this is what I
mean it's a perspective of time it's a
perspective of how context and
perspective ships it's so socially
undesirable for us to make that
admission now and what we say is that
that wasn't rational or philosophically
rigorous but even Nazism was thought to
be a product for certain idealist
tradition Houston Stuart Chamberlain
actually defected from an Anglo-Saxon
Burr to support a German file tradition
precisely on the basis they thought
idealism was a more active sentiment of
the Universe on the one in the society
that it could actually create a unified
notion of a folk so we have to be
careful with suggesting that those are
all mistakes when that's a progression
of the kinds of ideas these traditions
in the plurality of the West that you
think exists but somehow don't become
taken up but it seems to me that
underlying a lot of this this last few
minutes is is the fundamental question
of you know who says who says what and
and why and that's an objection you can
raise to anything and if we take it too
seriously then we can just quit go home
and not have a discussion right because
if you say well but who says that
Cosmopolitan is minced this as opposed
to that well I say one thing you say
another thing let's have a conversation
here and let's save that conversation
based on evidence reason on on actual
definitions and historical Trends etc
etc and I think that if we have that
conversation it will turn out that uh
thinking of Hitler Putin as Cosmopolitan
or universities he's just mistaken it's
just not the right way to think about it
regardless of whether they themselves
thought thought that way or not but you
can always argue the point absolutely
sure
I think there's a distinction as an
intellectual I would love to have that
conversation with you right because I
think it would be interesting you know
intellectual history
but I think there is something about the
relationship that power has to the idea
of the universal that's extended itself
into the problem of eliminating other
groups of people which is what we're
concerned with right so there is a
debate about how different people agree
or disagree about what good or bad is
okay what's moral or what's immoral but
the question is who has the power to
actually make those things relevant in
the real world such that they could
eliminate whole groups of people so the
reality of the situation is that whether
or not Hitler was suffering from a
mistaken identity of being a
Universalist is that he created a
certain system of power and deployment
of violence that certainly occupied a
moment within human history that gave
the illusion that this is a idea an
ideology or belief system that if it
would have won right would set the terms
of what we think the metaphysical
tradition between good and bad is so
we're working from the background of a
human history where Nazism lost but it
is possible that not just because it was
yes right well yes but but right but but
notice and this is what I mean though
notice how the the discourse on Power
and what we take is the historical epic
fundamentally changes the calculus that
we would have about what good and evil
is
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas